un homme tout nu
il a une barbe un soldat vers un petit
garçon tout le monde par terre certains
n'écoutent métaux faut geler tous les
mardis et un week-end sur dota compris
roga portier retard
tiens c'est amer moment ça va renchérir
tu peux mon goûter et j'ai pas encore
fait mes devoirs
comment il s'appelait qua non eh ben mon
village et o'gara mourdi des sorciers
[ __ ] on a intérêt à des cachettes ici
ils t'aiment jouer à quoi j'adore jouer
au docteur et toi ps n'oubliez pas vu un
homme d'aspect vulgaire pas très beau
avec un enfant c'est votre mari et non
oui comme vous le savez ce que je suis
une sorcière s comédienne mans comme tu
respires trompe les hommes de son âge
non
depuis des générations nous sommes des
gens maléfique maintenant tu me dis que
cet homme te plaît parce que c'est
quelqu'un de bien
moi l'essentiel me font pas peur par
contre ce qui me fait peur moi c'est les
fils de [ __ ]